battlefield 4 is a game that i hold
really close to my heart from constant
changes and improvements over the years
to help stabilize rough early launch
issues to fantastic spectacles in an
open sandbox
and an actually halfway decent campaign
what's up all
i'm david and this video is going to be
focused on battlefield 4 but we have
so many more battlefield videos cooking
up for 2042
so definitely subscribe and hit that
bell button so you'll always be in the
know your feedback means a lot to me
but for now let's take a quick trip
through memory lane
[Music]
i originally got into battlefield with
1942 on a garbage windows xp pc
playing against bots and staring at the
intro cutscene
absolutely stunned and convinced that
video games
reached their peak and looking realistic
now most of my time was spent running
around and looking for the planes and
various vehicles and just
cruising around my childhood best friend
was extremely into battlefield vietnam
and later on battlefield 2 but all i
knew was the prestige of the name and
experiencing those games second hand
fast forward to after being swept away
by modern warfare 2 and other entries in
the call of duty franchise throughout
middle in high school
and battlefield was a little absent for
my fps life
in 2013 battlefield 4 was my first real
experience with the series
when i actually played games as a hobby
now i had just received the xbox one
complete with the shitty kinect for my
birthday
and the only games that i had at launch
were forza 5 and ryze son of rome
i was desperate for something to play
and since i loved shooters
and was an early adopter of buying
digital games through the xbox store i
stumbled on battlefield 4.
now at this point i dove into the
campaign i know it's not the biggest
thing players go for nor is it the
primary mode battlefield is known for
but keep in mind back in 2013 before all
the battle royales and live service or
free-to-play games were everywhere
most shooters put as strong an emphasis
on single-player
as they did their multiplayer well no
with shooters you had about a 6 to 12
hour campaign
and then if you weren't an achievement
hunter you'd go into a hopefully
fun multiplayer with your buddies
battlefield 4
had the luxury of both by the time the
xbox one and ps4 generations was in full
swing
split screen co-op was quickly becoming
a distant memory
you either had to use xbox live and
separate consoles or you could just toss
the controller around and take turns
between lives which is what my buddies
and i did
and i mean all of my college doormates
and i played we didn't even play to win
or get a lot of kills and rock a wicked
kd
i actually didn't even know what good
kds were until years later when i
started going hardcore in a destiny in
call of duty pvp
what i do remember was when i first got
the game my roommate kept laughing when
i die
and at first i got pissed i thought he
was laughing at me when in fact
he was laughing at the situation and the
ways that the deaths were happening
i mean you're flying around crashing
into other jets or buildings you're on a
quad bike and you fly over a land mine
and blow up and explode like
that is funny we pass the controller
around and try to do dumb stunts
like really dumb like ignoring the
objectives and just
base jumping off of buildings trying to
do tricks on jets and fly as close to
the skyscrapers as you dare
knowing damn well if you mess up it'd be
another 10 minutes before you'd find
another jet
jump out of a plane and try to parachute
into a helicopter with your squad you
know only try to run people over with
the quad bike
just absolute silliness directly tied to
my fascination with battlefield 4 was
what allowed all of that crazy insanity
to happen in the first place
keep in mind a lot of mainstream aaa
games throughout the xbox 360 and
playstation 3 generation
were fairly linear and restrictive with
where you could go and what you could do
this was especially true when it comes
to multiplayer matches where you
effectively had a few objectives like
killing bad guys and going to capture
points
it's honestly a good time to mention
that every time i talk about battlefield
4 spectacle and moments of grandeur from
this point on
there's this equal amount of just comedy
like pure silliness and that separates
battlefield 4 from its successors in a
big way
battlefield 1 and 5 seem more focused on
trying to create this
gritty serious type atmosphere which is
fine i mean i love playing them both but
if there is
one thing about battlefield 4's
multiplayer it's that it never took
itself too seriously
and i mean just look at this how could
you keep a straight face
battlefield's contribution as a series
was sure do your normal objectives
but we won't tell you how you're
supposed to do it want to plant a tank
on a flag point
fine want to airmail your jet and then
parachute away into enemy territory
no problem want to just chill with your
squad and repair their vehicles
congratulations you're my new best
friend battlefield 4 stayed true to that
philosophy
and was just so open in establishing an
arena of creating as much mayhem
as possible battlefield truly loves
chaos
and battlefield 4 would up the ante with
levolution
now we go deep into why levolution was
so crazy in its own right in another
video
but to sum it up briefly here levolution
was a turning point in conquest matches
where the map would distinctly change
after being triggered by the players in
many instances
the iconic revolution in battlefield is
the siege of shanghai building
collapsing over objective point c
everyone has seen that one
and during the early launch period a
levolution infuriatingly usually ended
and getting booted from the server
because it was just too much for the
game to handle
but as patches came in and the game
started to stabilize
they quickly became highlights for me
the first time i saw
the heinen resort crumble in front of me
or that massive paracel storm aircraft
carrier
spectacularly crashed on shore all that
will always stay with me
and all this is to say that battlefield
4 not only had an
exceptionally grand and open sandbox but
this idea of spectacle
and silliness was everywhere and the
game encouraged an environment where
getting a high kd
was the last thing on my mind rather i
was here purely to tag along for those
battlefield moments these memories i had
with battlefield 4 give it an extremely
special place in my heart
and by far are the top reasons i will
always love this game
but whereas all this was subjective to
my own experience there are also a dozen
reasons why battlefield 4 was so damn
good from a support standpoint as well
and most of it involves at how
fine-tuned the gameplay became
to understand the leaps battlefield 4
has made you need to know what the game
was like at launch
battlefield 4 was a disaster with bugs
and net code issues
but with laser focus from dice that
persisted and was iterated upon
it eventually overcame a lot of its
struggles though not until
nearly a year later after its launch
which definitely
did not sit well with the community at
first it's worth noting that when we
talk about battlefield 4 as of right now
we're factoring in so much added post
launch content and dlc
a long list of varied maps an incredible
lineup of fun and distinct weapons and
weapon archetypes
most importantly there are a lot of
different game modes which always ensure
some degree of novelty and change
for those who are easily bored by
repetition if you're lukewarm on the
maps
that's fine since there always seemed to
be a new build strategy or even vehicle
that you can master
and for those premium and dlc owners the
content kept growing
there were so many broken metas and
ridiculous strategies used but despite
that hilarity
or frustration of those eras dice has
always been pretty solid about sandbox
tuning and the current state of the
battlefield 4 meta feels really good
another thing battlefield 4 has is a
very passionate community
which is reflected in the custom servers
that are available want to play only on
gold mud railway
no worries want a 24 7 operation locker
64 player server
here you go you maniac
right they were serviced with fast
respawn rates and others that harbored
fun spaces for battlefield fanatics
to always go back to and all of this
culminated in a complete battlefield
experience
that ironed out the launchier kinks and
allowed pc and console players to
properly enjoy the experience of a 64
player server
dialed up to an 11. the biggest reason
battlefield 4 is so
good is that it passes the basic smell
test
is this game fun and the answer being
absolutely which is really all that
matters at the end of the day
sure for some especially non-battlefield
veterans
it can take a minute to get adjusted to
the fact that
everything looks grey or brown or that
enemies tend to blend in with the
environment
but all of that quickly subsides a lot
of people like to compare battlefield 4
as a half step improvement over
battlefield 3.
and to that i say it really depends on
which one you grew up with
one thing i will say is that battlefield
4 had a much better balance between
grounded firefights
and absolute action movie mayhem than
battlefield 3 for starters
in battlefield 4 you wouldn't have your
entire vision get all blurry and
suppressed from taking damage for
instance
and the progression system in
battlefield 4 felt rewarding
rank-ups were awesome and unlocking new
cosmetics and skins for your guns to
unleash on your enemies
was just an added plus battlefield might
be the only shooter that doesn't exclude
any style of gamer either
the fact that i a casual love it so much
alongside the die hards
isn't the only proof battlefield does
not require what call of duty requires
which is rkd fast twitch skills above
all else you might not be going off on a
massive kill streak in battlefield all
the time
but no matter what kind of player you
are every action you take dramatically
contributes to your team
particularly in conquest in battlefield
it is not
uncommon to go several minutes without
firing a single shot
particularly if you're not playing
assault and diving in objectives
or if you're on a large map hell i've
seen helicopter pilots
just hover as high as possible over the
middle of the map to act as an extra
spawn zone
where we just spawn in only to jump out
immediately
to get a better vantage point mid map
battlefield gets better the more
imaginative that you get
and that might be the most important
reason why this game is so good
now that battlefield 2042 has been
announced and returned to a near future
setting
if you need something to get your feet
wet while waiting it is a perfect time
to return to battlefield 4.
the game is still going strong and has
plenty of fun servers
and i guarantee it will be a good time
now that i've gone a little misty eyed
on this game i want to hear your stories
as well
tell me what you remember fondly about
battlefield 4 or tell me what you're
excited about for 2042 in the comments
i read all of them thanks for watching
[Music]
so
you